>> I’M NOT SURE HOW MANY TIMES
IT HAS TO BE SAID, THE RISK OF
CHILDREN FROM THIS DISEASE FOR
FATALITY IS NEARLY ZERO.
I NEVER HEAR ANYONE TALK ABOUT
THE HARMS OF CLOSING SCHOOLS.
THE HARMS ARE AGAINST THE
CHILDREN, ANYONE WHO PRIORITIZES
CHILDREN WOULD OPEN THE SCHOOL.
THIS IS A LEVEL OF HYSTERIA.
I FEEL LIKE I’M LIVING IN A
COSTCO NOVEL HERE.
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
ARE STUNNED THAT WE ARE SIMPLY
WILLING TO DESTROY OUR CHILDREN
ON SOME BIZARRE NOTION THAT IS
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO THE
SCIENCE.
>> Sandra: THAT WAS SENIOR
FELLOW AT STANFORD’S HOOVER
INSTITUTION AND FORMER CHIEF OF
NEURORADIOLOGY AT STANFORD
MEDICAL CENTER.
ALL THIS REOPENING SCHOOLS THIS
FALL.
STATES LIKE FLORIDA ARE NOW
SEEING AN UPTICK IN CASES,
UNPRECEDENTED SURGES IN SOME
AREAS.
THE SUNSHINE STATE NOW HAS MORE
THAN 280,000 CONFIRMED CASES,
MORE THAN ALL THAT NINE
COUNTRIES WORLDWIDE.
FLORIDA SENATOR MARCO RUBIO IS
CHAIRMAN OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND JOINS US NOW WITH
MORE.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR.
I WILL ASK THE QUESTION THAT ALL
OF US AS PARENTS ARE ASKING EACH
OTHER, WE ARE ASKING THE LEADERS
OF THE LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL.
CAN OUR KIDS GET BACK TO SCHOOL
SAFELY, WILL THIS HAPPEN?
>> I THINK IT’S PRETTY CLEAR BY
NOW THAT THE PEOPLE RUNNING OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR STATES ARE NOT
GOING TO OPEN UP OUR SCHOOLS AS
LONG AS INFECTION RATES ARE AT A
CERTAIN LEVEL SO THAT PUTS THE
ONUS ON ALL OF US BE WHETHER YOU
BELIEVE IT’S SAFER NOT TO GET
THAT INFECTION RATES UNDER
CONTROL.
I HOPE AS WE MAKE THESE
DECISIONS THAT IT UNDERGOES THE
COST-BENEFIT ANALYSIS CLEARLY.
THERE IS THE BENEFITS OF CLOSING
SCHOOLS, AND THE COMMUNITY
SPREAD THAT WE ARE SEEING IN THE
OUTBREAKS, I UNDERSTAND IT’S NOT
INCONSEQUENTIAL AND IT’S A REAL
THREAT.
THE COSTS ARE SIGNIFICANT
THOUGH, IMAGINE IF YOU ARE A
SINGLE MOTHER THAT HAS TO BE AT
WORK EVERY DAY AT 8:00 A.M.,
YOUR JOB DEPENDS ON IT, WHAT DO
YOU DO WITH YOUR NINE YEAR OLD?
WHO ARE PROBABLY DROPPING THEM
OFF WITH THE LADY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD TAKES CARE OF EVERY
KID IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND
THAT’S RISKY, TOO.
IT HAS AN ECONOMIC IMPACT,
LEARNING IMPACT AND LONG-TERM
IMPACT WHICH WILL BE WITH US
LONG AFTER THE PANDEMIC HAS
PASSED.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE RISKS AS
LONG AS THERE IS NO IMMUNITY
FROM THIS VIRUS SO WE WILL HAVE
TO DO THE BEST WE CAN AND BE
FLEXIBLE.
BUT AT SOME POINT, SCHOOLS
REALLY DO NEED TO READ REOPEN.
>> Sandra: WE WILL TALK ABOUT
IT IN THE FALL, PLANNING HAS TO
BE IN PLACE TO SAFELY GET KIDS
BACK IN.
YOU GO BACK TO WHAT YOU JUST
HEARD FROM THE FORMER CHIEF OF
NEURORADIOLOGY AT STANFORD
MEDICAL CENTER TALKING ABOUT THE
HARM TO CHILDREN IF WE KEEP
SCHOOLS CLOSED.
HE SAID NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT
THAT?
>> THAT NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE
EQUATION.
AND THE HARM IS MORE THAN JUST
LEARNING GAMES.
A LOT OF THE CHILD-ABUSE
OCCURRENCES IN THE COUNTRY ARE
IDENTIFIED IN SCHOOLS WHEN YOU
SEE KIDS THROWING UP WITH
BRUISES AND OTHER INJURIES.
THAT’S WHY I THINK EVERY TEACHER
WHO HAS THE CONDITION OR SOMEONE
AT HOME SHOULD HAVE THE OPTION
OF BEING ABLE TO NOT BE FORCED
TO GO INTO WORK AND PUT THEIR
LIVES IN DANGER WITHOUT THEIR
LOVED ONE.
THE SAME AS STUDENTS WHO ARE NOW
IN THAT PREDICAMENT.
THERE HAS TO HAS TO BE A
NONSCHOOL OPTION BUT WE HAVE TO
BE EXTRA HARD TO BE AS FLEXIBLE
AS WE CAN’T FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET THOSE WHO DO NEED TO BE IN
SCHOOL INTO A BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITY SO THEY CAN LEARN.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
FOR WORKING FAMILIES.
I THINK MORE AFFLUENT FAMILIES,
THIS IS A BIG HASSLE BUT I THINK
THEY WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
THE ONES WHO WILL BE REALLY
IMPACTED OUR WORKING FAMILIES
AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
THOSE WHO DON’T HAVE THOSE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM.
>> Sandra: BUT WHAT CAN WE DO
REALISTICALLY?
TALK DETAILS.
FLORIDA IS A MESS, THERE’S NO
DOUBT.
CASES IN FLORIDA, 282,435, THAT
IS MORE CASES THAN ALL BUT NINE
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
SO WHAT DETAILS CAN YOU PROVIDE
US AT ABOUT DOING THAT?
HOW DO YOU GET THEM BACK INTO
THE BRICK AND MORTAR AS YOU
SAID?
>> A COUPLE OF POINTS.
THE FIRST IS FLORIDA IS AN
ENORMOUS STATE, WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF COUNTIES IN THE SITUATION YOU
ARE DESCRIBING YOURSELF AS, AND
I THINK THOSE COUNTRIES SHOULD
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE ABILITY TO
START SCHOOL ON TIME.
AND MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN OPEN
THE ENTIRE TIME, WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO BE AT 100%.
WE HAVE TO MITIGATE RISK.
AND THAT’S PLACES THAT WE CAN
TEACH OUTDOORS.
I DON’T THINK THAT THIS HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND PLACES THAT
LOCAL CONDITIONS AND WHAT THAT
IMPLIES.
ONE THING I’D LOVE TO SEE IS
SOME SORT OF MATRIX.
THAT SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER THE
RISK AND TAKE IT BACK HOME TO
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS.
>> Sandra: EVERY PARENT WANTS
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THEIR
CHILD, BUT THEY WANT TO SEE A
PRIORITY ON CHILDREN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS GEORGETOWN PROFESSOR PUT
OUT A FASCINATING PIECE IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
TALKING ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
SACRIFICE THEIR LIVES.
THEY STAYED HOME TO PROTECT
SOMEBODY LIKE HIM IN A HIGH-RISK
CATEGORY AND HE SAID NOW, IT’S
MY OBLIGATION AS A TEACHER TO
GET BACK ON CAMPUS THIS FALL.
MY UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT HAVE
ONLY FOUR YEARS IN COLLEGE AND
MY LAW STUDENTS, ONLY THREE IN
LAW SCHOOL.
I HAVE CLEAR MEMORIES OF HOW
FLEETING THOSE YEARS ARE.
WE KNOW THERE IS RISK, BUT WE
WANT TO GET THE SENSE OF URGENCY
THAT THESE TEACHERS,
SUPERINTENDENTS AND THEN OF
COURSE THE MAYORS AND THE
GOVERNORS OF THE STATES ARE
PLACING URGENCY ON THIS AND
PRIORITIZING KIDS AND
PRIORITIZING EDUCATION.
>> THAT’S PART OF A CATCH UP
THAT’S NOT BEING TAKEN INTO THE
ACCOUNT.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WORK AT
WALGREENS, THEY ARE GOING TO
WORK EVERY DAY AND HAVING TO
PROTECT THEM.
SOME OF THOSE SIMILARITIES IN
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET BACK INTO THE SCHOOL.
MAYBE STARTING A LITTLE LATER,
MAY BE FLEXIBLE WITH THE
SCHEDULING BUT AGAIN THE BIGGEST
LOSERS IN THIS DECISION-MAKING
WILL BE LOWER INCOME AND WORKING
FAMILIES WHO DO NOT HAVE THOSE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM TO
SIMPLY LEAVE THEIR KIDS AT HOME
AND DO NOT HAVE A SCHOOL THAT IS
OPEN.
SO I DO HOPE WE TAKE IT MORE
SERIOUSLY.
IT’S NOT THE SORT OF DECISION
THAT SHOULD BE MADE CAVALIERLY
ON THE BASIS OF SOME OF THE
PRESSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO START START
FINISH UP BY ASKING ABOUT YOU,
TED CRUZ, AND THE AMBASSADOR FOR
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM,
SAM BROWNBACK.
YOU’VE BEEN TARGETED NOW BY
CHINA WITH SANCTIONS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL OF THE
COUNTRY’S ACTIONS TOWARDS
MINORITY GROUPS AND PEOPLE OF
FAITH.
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE AND CAN
YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE ON THE
SITUATION?
>> IS PRETTY SIMPLE.
CHINA IS THE TOTALITARIAN REGIME
REGIME, AND THEIR RELIGIOUS
IDENTITY AND THEIR NAMES, THEY
CALL IT REEDUCATION CAMPS AND IN
MANY CASES THOSE ARE NOT, THEY
ARE FORCED LABOR CAMPS.
IT’S AN OUTRAGE AND I WILL
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT ON IT.
I HAVE NO INTENTION OF TRAVELING
TO CHINA ANYTIME SOON ANYWAY.
I’M ACTUALLY PROUD OF IT.
I DIDN’T LOOK FOR IT AND I’M
PROUD OF THAT BAND BECAUSE IT
SHOWS WE ARE ON THE RIGHT SIDE.